HAVE you heard all that advertising from the Aldi
because it is just different
you normally hear them a lot in commercials
no cheap voice actors anywhere this week
like actor didrik ebbingen from the Aldi commercials
sure Aldi
and making 1 advertisement with voice actor
of course costs money
then just fuck off dude
Aldi prefers to do that from now on
to save costs in our advertising
we came up with something clever
because the store chain
has replaced voice actor didrik with 1 AI after 4 years
vote and that's me
the new voice of Aldi
is beautiful
I am ready day and night and I never have a cold
that AI
voice
is based on the votes of 10 Aldi employees
from the store
the distribution center and the office
experts expect that in the future
AI voices will be used much more often
there makes the art bond
who stands up for people in the cult and creative
sector is concerned about
we see that work slowly go away
and we see those people
just later
can no longer work and
can no longer earn money
people who
also show that uh that they are no longer asked
who uh
the voices were from uh de Albert heijn in the shops
that is no longer asked
and they are more uh places
so yes we get to hear a lot about that